servus kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video heute spielen wir gerd
daun mit dem get down heino meine nummer
eins nie gespielt hat einen kleinen
challenger nehmen wir die challenge wie
man lieber es katy wörterbuch channel
natürlich die wochenenden oder die
wörter wenn du nicht erlebt hast was
meinst du richtig und zwar musst du
jetzt bei dieser runde für jedes mal wo
du auf einen kleinen block gehen willst
musst du davor einen essbaren gegenstand
zeigt mal oder ein gericht mit frucht
sonst was mit dem buchstaben p kay leute
kurze ansage - gerade im beim schneiden
aufgefallen dass wir die challenge gar
nicht so richtig erklärt haben was
wörterbuch challenge bedeutet ist in
jeder runde kriege ich eine neue
challenge mir zu einem buchstaben
gewisse wörter auszudenken sollen in der
ersten runde ist der buchstabe und es
geht um essen und nur wenn ich ein essen
das mit den buchstaben p beginnt geraten
habe oder mir ausgedacht habe darf ich
auf dem blog in der nächsten runde ist
dann halt kein essen sondern was anderes
und nach buchstabe das so das prinzip
also dass ich quasi das wörterbuch bin
und mir zu einem gewissen buchstaben
wort aus dem gewissen themenkreis
aussuchen muss sonst darf ich nicht auf
die comeback gegeben
ok zurück zum video doch dort ist leicht
papaya bis leicht sagt papa ja ich bin
schon drauf gegangen ich hoffe dass zb
ist in ordnung war schon vorstellen aber
beim nächsten blog warte ich weiß warum
ich papa weil die moderatorin
achtung jetzt hier sind kein dogma
der fahrer eines mit die hamas ohne
pommes stimmt so schwer ist schwer junge
länder richtig knapp wenn du dich jetzt
gar nicht gedacht also ich habe eine
normale sache vor augen pilze zählt das
passt
willkommen in minecraft
ich bin zwar elite und ich hab ich bin
froh die kraft nicht nur noch dieses
prädikats ok ab sofort sagst du mir
einnahmen mit nina und nochmal direkt
nochmal direkt ist noch mal eine nils
junge spieler richten kontakter die box
dieser hund ist bitter aber er ist
gestorben
jubel kommt noch einer
eure chinesen vorfahren soll sterben ja
den vorfahren damit die niemals auf die
welt kommen
da wird schon sagen weil dann wären der
niemand hat erhält okay ich bin
irgendwie unkonzentriert sonst bin ich
suche ja du musst ja auch nicht
mitspielen muss man nur fragen stellen
aber ich wäre ja auch einen namen mit l
sind aber zu leicht machen irgendwas
schwierigeres machen was was
spezifischer das wäre automaten mit mit
b ja da hast du gemacht und das war
illegal
leider habe ich nicht ob ich nicht ob
ich nicht jetzt hier ist ein bmw
ich fühle mich fokus da oben die vier
werden von mir geht weg von mir du hast
des weges er gestorben
deswegen sollte die leute mich
draufgehen okay noch eine mit bugatti
jungen er finde ich einfach und gebrauch
soll er sie noch gewusst bitte was jetzt
noch bewusst bentley
borgward auch noch ist ja auch noch
eingefallen
ihr könnt mich aus neuenstein challenge
was muss ich sagen
computerspiele mit ssc handyspiele auch
ja ja ja sicher ok also einfach quasi
spiele games games digital games
rufnamen rights movement junge früher im
urlaub haben wir das richtig krass
gesuchte tier glaubt es nicht mal ne kam
vom strand also vom sommerurlaub haben
uns in unserem verein den gang gesetzt
dabei erwarte ich es als ob ich habe
gewonnen
wie findet ihr denn so schnell war ja
danke das zu stellen finde ich habe 500
kompass da egal alles gut ja was ich
hätte kein problem mit essen ins spiel
zu finden computerspiele star wars
battlefront hätte ich noch gesagt ja was
sonic und mario bei den olympischen
spielen natürlich kann ich mir von dir
und ich würde aber gucken ja aber da
habe ich keine kohle mehr junge ich muss
den stein schwert holen weiß rieder
struggles ich habe ein scharfes 41 ja
erfreut mich für dich max freut mich
wirklich fest warum weil du mich
eigentlich nicht so leute die change
geht weiter im deathmatch wirklich sagen
wir sind bei spielen mit es so ich habe
eben
wir haben dann eben schon mal gesagt was
mir noch eingefallen wäre habe ich
gesagt
star wars battlefront und sonnig aber
jetzt muss ich mir noch weitere
einfallen lassen ab jetzt will ich mir
sage ich muss jetzt den kampf angesagt
weil hier ist okay jetzt wenn ich diesen
ein beispiel angreifen will
ein computerspiel mit es computerspiele
mit s
erstklassig auch keine seghers kein nerd
ist ein hersteller die gassen herrscht
eine mega super super irgendwas gibt
super smash bros
ja ja jetzt sogar super super dazu aber
richtig logic alter naja und haltbarkeit
wird sich mit mir anlegen bis juli starb
niemand
ich bin mittlerweile richtig gute kunst
eigentlich für diesen waschbeton motor
schlagen ist meine einzige chance
nämlich zu kehren wenn wir kein geld
mehr
ich habe so viele gegner gefunden in
meinem leben
es gibt mich hoffentlich nicht aber es
war schon relativ taliban oder macht er
nicht
davon ist sein ok ich muss mich mal was
mit mit es ausdenken sss stw she
dieses computerspiel vorher wie
skifahren auf laptop ist das was ich bin
oft hinter dem premium her
was ist aus elkhart mit der angel
richtiges wasser zieht ats ss-leute
dornauf seiner rüstung was ist los mit
dem bus rainer und jungen des franken
respekt des gegners mit s ich weiß nicht
davon völlig töten alter wie viel text
ein feuer ist bei 1 3 bis 1 5 oder 6
ticks wahrscheinlich irgendwas mit super
also 1000 sachen mit ja
die g8 als quali crafter vielleicht bist
du ja ich bin zayed
wir wollten ja man sieht ob er recht
jedoch team erlaubt deswegen ist okay ja
welches onkel machen will was mit s ich
kam ja während du dir vielleicht das was
überlegen alle kräfte also dass das ding
sap muss sich noch einstellen dass die
ganz natürlich bremst ok es
saints row saints row es stimmt wir sind
die letzten zeit ideen hab ich dich
kenne kannst vielleicht irgendwie wert
abgeben dass wir verfallen machen oder
so was kann ich machen ich habe ganz
welches runter imagine könnte richtig
abgestaubt
aber klar aber so nicht ankommen hoch
foto computer
ja aber da unten aber so wenig platz da
kann man nicht kämpfen ich wollte ein
paar dafür würde ich sagen kannst geben
danke danke martin klinger ich will so
kommen wir machen was lust da geht mir
nahe wenn du eine hast ja dann geht man
also wenn du zwei nimmt die angel und
angel mich schwer teuer
die angel bestürzt aber wahrscheinlich
nicht ich weiß nur dass mein herz ist
ein junge ja ich werde stück alter nein
was machst du auch nicht diese ich mache
genau diese spielstark und yahoo
einsteins werden
das war zwar hoch gehen
das macht ihn dargestellt soviel zum
thema abnahmen
was denn schneller darauf nein
ja ich finde es hier den gold abgeben
können